so the way that this is going to work is
I'll open it up with a few directed
questions for you Gary and then after
about you know 15 minutes or whenever we
get really bored we're going to move
into the audience on the confusing the
crowd Mike did you just say that I was
going to be boring in the first 15
minutes yes no I said that after we get
bored with my question we want a
consistent but I'm glad he brought that
up because I think that by inviting you
here especially to kick off this is kind
of where we stop being polite and we
start getting real right and my first
question for you is kind of a generic
question but the question is how
powerful is the combination of purpose
and innovation I'm asking this because I
think that we need to hold ourselves
accountable like is this just another
cheesy conference theme that doesn't
mean anything or does it actually mean
like from your perspective what's the
power in that combo um yes it's a it's
both it's a cheesy conference theme and
it's real right I mean I think at the
end of the day you know innovation
purpose these are very clear I mean it's
kind of like the value of oxygen or you
know like like of course like anybody
who's sitting here that doesn't think
that innovation matters or disrupts or
is a key of how we you know evolve as
people or that it's a hell of a lot
better to have a purpose behind what
you're doing then not is is tone-deaf to
the reality of what creates upside both
as a human and as a business yeah so
then it's just about implementation
right like how do we do this and so
meaning execution yeah execution
implementation so so I know a lot of you
don't know who I am unless you saw me
two years ago I'm I get a lot of flack
in the technology space I was an early
investor in facebook and twitter and
uber and did really well and have a lot
of street cred in that world and in that
world all of them are super upset with
me because I always say that ideas are
crap right ideas are crap because I get
10,000 emails a week from people that
want me to
companies and they tell me that they
have the greatest idea of all time
everybody in here has an idea the amount
of times somebody comes up to me goes oh
I had the uber idea before it happened
great what do you want a cookie like
like like like ideas are completely
completely completely worthless
unless you execute against those ideas
and you can sit here and tell me what
your purpose is but unless you go and
execute against it it's no different
than something like an idea which is
completely meaningless without
fundamental execution okay all right so
a lot of us here do have ideas but what
one of the biggest roadblocks and we do
want cookies - yes I one of the biggest
other late on that note I do this a lot
that set up in the back with the candies
in the stuff that's pretty legit so
let's we should clap up the candies like
I didn't even see that set up and oh you
if you know me back there I'm telling
all right so if you want to make some
candy because you have ideas not just
that but what if that's a roadblock for
us like how do we get other people on
board with our ideas you mean within the
organization right because a lot of
these folks are going to go home in
three days or pumped up about the things
they've heard here and and like Sam
mentioned everyone's going to say oh you
went to that conference yes so so over
the last seven years I built my family's
liquor store into one large e-commerce
wine businesses in America I went out
and started investing companies that did
well and then seven years ago I decided
that I was going to build a client
service agency to help the biggest
brands in the world understand where the
world was going how to market you know
the days of making TV commercials and
print advertising are not dead but their
waning their very overpriced by
comparison as some of the opportunities
that we see in facebook environments and
things of that nature and the thing that
I didn't know because I'm an
entrepreneur when I make all my
decisions I just have to go home look
myself in the mirror make a call and
then go and move i I've had to deploy an
enormous amount of empathy to understand
how many of you don't have that ability
and so there's a lot of different ways
to answer your question and I used to be
really frustrated with everybody here
because I didn't think they had enough
gusto to go home and do it now I'm at a
place where I mainly blame the CEO
of all the companies that they work for
or the board or Wall Street for creating
90-day behavior because everybody Maps
towards their stock price there's a
million different ways to go about it
look I think the number one thing you
can do is actually the best advice I
have for human beings which is
communicate whether it's your spouse or
your children or your parents or
something you care about communication
is the game figuring out how to be
politically correct is not the answer
figuring out how to tell people what you
believe the company should be doing in a
respectful manner that's the game and so
look my belief is that 98% of the people
in this room can't do anything with what
they learned this weekend I mean it it's
not fun to say but it's true I now work
with enough big companies and I
understand and more importantly the
stuff that I most believe in and worthy
it look I think the one thing we're all
grounded in is the end consumers
attention you have a you have a branding
issue we talked about this two years ago
I'm here two years later I looked at the
Google searches I looked at the social
media mentions people still don't know
what credit unions are like let's cut to
the chase your mcoms issue as an
industry yeah let alone as your
individual companies and so the really
sad part and we have financial service
clients and alcohol brands and
government stuff like I work with this
there's way too many people in this room
and definitely the logos that they work
for that use compliance as an excuse for
not doing what's right in a 2016
environment and so you know what should
they do they should tell people what
they believe within their organization
top down left right the truth is most
people actually don't know what they
actually want to do that we're living
the world right now of headline readers
the majority of people in here that
really understand the tactical
executions within these new
communication platforms are almost
non-existent you might have read an ad a
chart achill or the Wall Street Journal
about what's happening in facebook
snapchat Instagram but do you really
know how work or it's like oh we'll just
hire a young person right you think
about a 24 year old millennial yeah and
the problem with that is that young
people are often inexperienced with
strategy good quick like who's got an
idea
raise your hand you have an idea
come on and I believe these no one has
an ideal I came at the wrong conference
that could be a problem that is a big
problem Gary we're gonna have to rewind
are you getting ideas oh look I think
everybody has an idea nobody wants to
raise your hand because they they know
that I'm crazy enough to jump out here
and maybe punched a minister so I repeat
to Waimea and raise their hands but go
ahead where were you gonna go with that
so everyone so everybody has like
alright let me save you time they all
have ideas next I want to let them to
leave ahead of it actually told somebody
about it look the problem is it's not
their fault I used to think it was their
fault it's not their fault they don't
work in organizations that best for an
environment or a culture that actually
rewards that kind of behavior now don't
use that as an excuse though you know
because that's the fun thing to clap on
like it yeah it's the man it's the
Machine like like all of you should quit
and start your own companies if you have
such a good idea okay
I'm laughing I that's what I did and
actually funny enough it was actually
your web 2.0 do what you love torque was
one of those big triggers it's like do
you know it's one of the things that's
really thing as which is about purpose
and I and I opened it as well it's fine
your purpose what's the problem that you
find a deep intrinsic purpose and want
to solve it if that means leaving your
credit union sorry see here but that
might be one of the option you know it's
funny it's the way it's funny how you
are positioned my talk right we're going
to get real it's going to get
uncomfortable my purpose when I publicly
speak is to be very frank I'm just
hopeful that I can break through to one
person in this room I'm very practical
about how this goes I do think people
get inspired and think differently in an
off site and things of that nature but I
have empathy and understanding and
understand how the world works in an
entrepreneurial event I actually think a
lot of things can go and happen they
just don't have the friction or the red
tape but when you work within an
organization it's harder to make change
especially if you don't run it and so I
would tell you that sharing content has
worked one of the things that I've seen
really work it like now we're cut
instead of pontificating and peacocking
let me answer this
quickly if you really care about this
and you believe in certain theories I
would find these videos and articles
online and I would share them via email
within your organization chipping away
like a woodpecker over and over with
that content has actually brought a lot
of change with a lot of big
organizations I also think things like
this but on a company-wide level where
you bring in people that are thinking
about the world differently than you
with senior leadership at the event has
been a very remarkable way to do change
it makes me sad that my company has done
two or three or four years of good work
sold a lot of products for clients but
we may move the needle just a little bit
and then maybe one keynote that I do
with leaders moves the organization 10x
and so I don't like that because I feel
like that's over valuing sizzle over
steak but it's the reality of how human
behavior works so I do think if you have
the power to create off-site events or
program information to senior leadership
in whatever environment you know one
thing that somebody took from advice
from a talk like this she joined the
committee that puts together the end of
the year off site and then programmed a
bunch of characters that look like me
and it was the most meaningful thing
that happened to that organization they
changed her behavior and are having one
of their best years in 17 years right
now as a publicly traded company so
there's there's things to do it's fun to
clap that the man doesn't let you and
your organization doesn't support it but
at the end of the day we should really
put our big girl big-boy pants on and
try to figure out how to make it happen
that's obviously to the individuals what
a question he has come through I want
you to answer this to the CEOs of these
companies the question is how can they
foster more entrepreneurial culture
internally force it being a CEO is being
a dictator create the rules simple
Breanna Dahlia you're the CEO make the
rules force everybody spend 20% of their
money on things that don't have an ROI
that is scored within internal are
things that you've never done before and
reward people for the behavior or
spending 20% of their time and money on
something that you can't measure or that
you've done historically you just solve
it there you go go do that so just a
quick reminder everyone you can ask Gary
by the way I apologize this is important
to me I'm a CEO of my company have 650
employees I tell them that they get
scored on culture and emotional
intelligence over bringing me money over
doing the best work that it is the North
Star the North Star that people get
rewarded for is how they play with the
other girls and boys within the
organization because I like continuity
because continuity leads to speed I
think speed is the most important thing
in business and then when we reward it
we're the nicest people get raises and
promotions even though they may be a be
Talent and the guy who's an a talent but
is a little bit of a douchebag doesn't
get promoted that everybody starts
believing what I actually care about
because being a CEO is a dictatorship so
I make the rules and then I act on them
so go do that so just a quick reminder
every one you can ask Gary questions
through the sink fix a nap and I will
come up here on my little tablet here so
if you have a question do punch it
through through the application take all
the questions there's no more I feel
like that we're actually running up oh I
would love for more questions for this
but one of the drunk jump in the
audience and ask questions all I think
you know my browser yeah so let me just
let me just move it back because I think
a lot a lot of people I see people
nodding their heads like yeah we do have
a comms issue what about the folks were
like the number one problem in my
organization is communications but I
don't know anything about communications
it's not my specialty or technology I
don't know anything about technology I'm
sort of like I'm an accountant I'm an
engineer honestly you know I mean yeah
what about those folks
well first they may not be right about
comms being a problem because if they're
not experts in an order stand that they
may as a focus group of one think that
the organization's not doing the best
job but first they want to be grounded
and actually knowing the craft and
what's happening I mean look there's a
lot of organizations that are getting a
lot of ROI from their traditional media
spends and things of that nature
it's just that they haven't put
themselves in a position to test direct
mail or sales driven organizations or
whatever they may be doing it against
some of the new behaviors you know I
think they go and talk to their
counterparts with the new organizations
and I think they tread lightly which is
like hey Katherine I know this isn't my
domain but have we thought about doing
these other things or what are we doing
those things I'm curious as a consumer
of where we're going I mean again it's
just good old-fashioned communications
but I do think it's dangerous when you
when you don't have cross disciplines I
mean it's amazing to me how all 650
people that work for me have plenty of
ideas of what the CEO should be doing
but it's really easy to say that when
you're not the last line of defense and
you don't have all the context to why
what's the hardest thing about being a
CEO and trying to get an organization to
change culture change slowly it's hard
yeah you know being a CEO is hard you
know especially when it's your business
you know if I'm a CEO in corporate
America I'm a hell of a lot more
interested because even if you fail you
still get enormous cash bonuses on your
way out so that's interesting that I
like being an entrepreneur of an
independent company like myself is if I
stink we go out of business and you
don't get the bonuses and you don't get
the accolades and you know my business
my life is predicated on headaches you
know 20 minutes before I got here I was
in my hotel room here it's so beautiful
here I don't know if you saw the oceans
gorgeous everyone's had a good time
there's candy for days in a back room
and what am i doing I mean I'm in my
room dealing with four major headaches
problem at the problem at the problem
plus I'm an HR driven CEO so I like to
get into the muck so you know meaning
like I really fundamentally care about
their opinions on you know I'm really
the head of HR even though I just hired
a chief heart officer to really enforce
HR but you know mom-mom I could be on a
call in a couple hours that's Susan who
says hey Gary
Karen's trying to ruin me you know that
could be like 40 minutes of my day you
know so you know what's it like to be a
CEO it's lonely you know listen it's
really fun to be able to clap up like
yeah it's the Machine it's the man I sit
in front of my entire 75 person office
in LA and said look just so you
understand everything that is wrong with
this company is my fault all of it
because I empower all the other people
that are screwing up right so so you
know how is it for me I love it it's you
know I love the action I'm an
entrepreneur
it's it's my oxygen I couldn't do
anything else have never worked for
anybody else I don't know another gear
it's my DNA but it's not that easy like
we're living through the greatest era of
fake entrepreneurship right now in
America because everybody in their 20s
is popping out and they're the next Mark
Zuckerberg we have 99% of those
companies about to go out of business
once the next financial crisis which I
hope happens soon comes so that we can
wipe out all this fake entrepreneurship
and all this bull crap but you know but
it's hard yeah I mean you look at the
universities in America right now that
have entrepreneurship at the forefront
Babson UPenn they have the highest rate
of suicide because a lot of kids right
now think that it's just so easy to like
when did this happen when did everybody
just think they can build a
million-dollar business just because you
live in America and you're 24 and you
have a hoodie right and you go we were
like in about wearing matching Eddie
what is what's happened like there's a
there's a stunning conversation because
entrepreneurship is very Americana it's
very hot right now but being a micro
industry celebrity it's crazy to me how
much the entrepreneur is being put on a
pedestal I'm feeling it enormous Lee and
and I think it's dangerous because I
don't think people think they can just
be LeBron James I don't think people
think they can just be Beyonce I don't
think they could think they can just be
these things yet for some reason we're
in this place right now where we think
we can just build these million-dollar
businesses and entrepreneurship is a
skill it's a talent it's like if you
know most are born with it you could be
better at it but to be a great one and
then and then we have a crazy
conversation around income like the
facts at the bottom of the one-percent
earners in this country make four
hundred thousand dollars a year yet all
these 20 year olds think that a million
dollars a year is like the baseline for
like maybe being in the game we are just
completely in the outer space right now
on this conversation yeah interesting
kids it's wonderful getting your blog
live while you're on stage okay there
what a question on your blog it says in
your last post you talked about you can
empathy to make a sale yes how can this
audience use empathy in their daily
business I think I think empathy is the
greatest trait that I was gifted by my
other and and I use it everyday I think
it makes me a great salesperson I think
way too many organizations don't deploy
empathy ever and and most of all not on
their end consumer they most of you
think way too much inside of a bubble
and you get into a room and you
whiteboard in things that are in your
best interest but not in the end
consumers best interest so empathy is
completely left that at the garbage
before you walk into the door and for me
I try to run my organization and my
offerings and when I sold wine and when
I sell books and when I sell client
services and whatever I do for the rest
of my life my goal is always how do I
deploy 51% of the value of this
transaction to the other party and I use
empathy I try to understand why this
organization needs to take a step back
and understand why nobody in America
knows what a credit union is that would
be the first step to a lot more money
made for everybody in this room not your
emotional to why it's not happening
not that it should be happening not
succumbing to it's happening but
understanding why it's happening and
then that would help and the way to do
that is to deploy empathy and understand
what's happening in people's day and day
our lives that isn't allowing us to
penetrate them with the messaging that
describes what we do for a living and
what are some of the techniques you use
to gain you know an empathetic
understanding of the consumer like if
you were in the credit unions would you
do consumer polls would you go talk to
students sir how do you actually do that
you know yeah that's a good question so
I think I think what you just mentioned
are non empathetic machines doing
tactics to try to fake empathy what I
would do is try to find empathetic
people and empower them to do [ __ ]
pretty simple I mean I mean it like I
don't know like like you know what's
funny but how many people from I can
help people how many people in this room
I'm going to I want to see this how many
people saw the big short great I
literally believe that marketing and
running businesses in America are going
oh if we can keep this on to be amazing
cuz I'd like to start interacting with
everybody
um I literally believe that that's
what's happening with marketing and
running businesses in America right now
everybody knows but like nobody's doing
anything about it like 90% of my
customers are throwing their money
directly in the trash like like watch
this this is gonna be fun this I let's
agree on a couple things let's agree
that this is not a 14 year old aged
teenage girl crowd right can we agree on
that good by show of hands how many
people in this room now when they watch
television watch it on their time not
watching it when it actually aired but
outside of live sports you watch on TiVo
DVR Netflix you know on-demand raise
your hands Oh weird everybody how many
of you when given the option fast
forward every single commercial raise
your hands everybody and even if you're
lucky enough excuse me even if my
clients at Toyota Unilever Pepsi are
lucky enough that you get a commercial
shown to you because I don't know
you dropped your remote control off the
bed right even if that happens the
second something goes into commercial
every one of you grabs this my friend's
attention is the only thing that matters
before you can tell me how great your
credit union is how great your sneakers
are how great your book is how great
your service is how great your jam that
you make in your home is that you want
to sell me before you do any of that you
have to have my attention and then you
can tell me your story the organizations
in the world organizations in this room
are throwing good money directly in the
trash because they're marketing like
it's 2009 2004 nineteen ninety seven or
nine
72 this is an old crowd and none of you
are consuming commercials and 80 billion
dollars are being spent to make them and
distribute them nobody here is going
home and carefully going through their
direct mail and and and so you know I
don't know what people think is
happening like like you're like I don't
understand how this you know your same
tactics aren't bringing results like you
you know that that trade show that you
go to every year and spend a ton of
money on on your awesome booth is not
returning the same results yet we just
keep doing it as if nobody gives a crap
that's sort of like the definition of
insanity doing the same thing over and
over and expecting different results
right we've all heard that same a
hundred percent and you go we're I'm
sorry people say to me in marketing like
I'm such a disruptor I'm so crazy I'm so
dis I think it's crazy to make
commercials in 2017 like it's not
practical I think I'm quite practical I
know that an enormous how many people
here look at their Facebook profile and
their feed and their page raise your
hands
how many of you use Facebook raise it
high don't be scared I just know you're
thinner and I know I could sell you
stuff there Facebook is selling billions
of dollars of stuff per month like I
don't understand like I don't understand
how you think you act one way at home
right but then when you put your suit on
and go to work
you have different strategies because of
the room that you're in yet when you
leave all your feet the fastest-growing
demo of selfies on Instagram or forty
five year old women oh yeah any forty
I'll women's yeah they'll be really cool
or selfies for days 50% of this room in
24 months is going to be living in
snapchat 80% of it does doesn't even
consider using snapchat right now this
is a great segue he uses snapchat
so Gary how how many people here have
never heard of snapchat it's okay raise
your hands that in itself is pretty
impressed that's and it's maybe you know
what in 18 months I'm moving faster and
I thought God how can credit unions use
snapchat well first of all credit unions
today have to decide if they want to
court thirteen to twenty five year olds
do you great well then you better figure
it the hell out because I think a lot of
you didn't the reason almost everybody
but that one random dude has not has
heard of snapchat is because anybody in
this room that has a thirteen to twenty
two-year-old anything in their lives
granddaughter grandson daughter nephew
niece knows that that human being lives
in one place their phone and on two
things snapchat and Instagram so how you
gonna tell them about your thing how you
gonna tell them like how you gonna get
to them you're not and you're gonna
spend it on bullcrap if you want to get
to 13 to 25 now here's the important
thing I believe snapchat is going
through the same thing Facebook did it's
13 to 25 now but when wake up in 18
months and it's 13 to 45 I have a funny
feeling a lot more of you are interested
in that 25 to 45 year old demo just as
well and that's where people get caught
you don't project
everything's credit kid on today but
it's really not because if you look at
your behavior motion companies are
marketing like it's 10 years ago but you
know I mean there's a real I do social
media consulting right and I have a hard
time keeping up something I really you
know so the thing is is how do we keep
pace with technology and we sat in
Warmerdam and you work ok
like sorry that it's moving fast like
liquid oh right like we're all
professionals here like sorry like sorry
that the world's moving super fast you
know some dude owned 80 thousand horses
when the car was invented he lost
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hater you know like like tough luck like
innovation doesn't care about you and me
you think I'm excited to be up at two
o'clock in the morning trying to figure
out mine like I did you know three years
ago I actually think you are excited to
be here you might be right actually you
know what's funny you nailed it
I am excited because I know my
differentiation ship in the marketplace
is that I'm learning to outwork my
competition I know that I got lucky that
I wasn't born in America so I understand
how good it actually really is here and
I'm thinking full goddamn advantage of
it but but but this is what I hear all
the time and I know a lot of you know
this right like like and this this is
very pungent to the you know 50 and
older crowd that I see in this room guys
I am NOT interested in this excuse that
I didn't grow up with it
I didn't grow up with it I'm 40 when I
was 18 years old I spent five minutes on
a computer in my entire life I didn't
grow up with it
you didn't grow up driving you figured
that out yeah you know so this excuse
that you didn't grow up with this it's
just not an excuse you're more than
welcome to not use it as a human being
I'm not in charge of that but if you
were in the business world and you were
disrespecting these platforms you are
vulnerable yeah I didn't grow up with it
is more like I'm just not interested in
that no it's just that you know what I
don't really give a crap I'm tired I've
been working a long time I hate that
it's changed it's not my best interest I
spent 20 years growing in this
organization and now I know something
and now the whole thing is being changed
on me I don't like that I don't want
that to happen I would make a couple of
don't sit there yeah sorry but but this
is the dangerous formula that a lot of
you are going through I have empathy you
know it stinks if you're in PR and you
spent 22 years in it and you moved up
the ranks and you got all those
relationships and now it doesn't matter
as much
I get it I'm not happy about it I just
don't know any other gear than dealing
in reality I wake up every morning
trying to put myself out of business
what do I sell and how do I sell it and
who could put me out of business
and I'd rather do that that's how I
innovate you know how I enemy I try to
create products and services and do
behavior that is the behavior that would
hurt me if somebody else did it because
it's a hell of a lot more fun to put
yourself out of business than have
somebody else do it for you
so I can connect a couple of dots here
from what you've been saying okay one
empathy without understand why something
exists yes
then we've got onto snapchat okay now I
know the answers questions I can bail
out if you don't know know the answer
why does snapchat exist
why does snapchat exist because
communication is the foundation of how
human beings act and communication has
gone from drawing stuff inside of caves
to standing on top of mountains and
making smoke signals go read go read
what people wrote about the invention of
the telephone it was going to ruin us we
made it right snapchat exists because it
was an ideation and an evolution of
communication within the mobile device
which is the single most important thing
in our society guys how many people here
within every 24 hours including when
they're sleeping are always within arm's
reach of their telephone raise your
hands high
look at this not fourteen-year-old girls
and the important point is 10 years ago
50% of the audience with a sworn they'll
never get a cell phone that's right and
so there's six year old dudes in here
who texted a poop emoji last night I
mean look at this lovely ladies got to
technology devices a phone and ID and
she's 80 years old
[Laughter]
kidding are you on snapchat as well like
what but the point is the point is and
obviously I was going for the lap there
you look you look amazing I'm going to
kiss you on the face when I get done
with this talk I want people are saying
you guys know this your parents are on
this this is real like how are you
possibly disrespecting this Phil because
your organization doesn't support
digital spend or digital native
activities it's crazy it's over I don't
care how you want it to be it's the way
it is and by the way you take the
negative view on this let me talk to you
about something that's going on in
society that I know all of you have
judged you go out to a restaurant and
you see a couple and they're having
dinner and they're both on the phone and
you just love to say to your partner hey
do you see that how sad right you love
that right
you love judging don't you right here's
what I see I see two people that 15
years ago would had dinner together what
is set across from each other and one of
them have said a damn word to each other
remember those conversations you've seen
that couples sitting right next to you
not a word so you know what I think this
is it's a blessing to those two SSS it
is I'm happy for those two people that
they can actually be doing what they
actually want to be doing sure Sam you
got a question this thing on here I am
okay so this is we talked about this
that marketers credit union marketers it
does have to get the story out we have
this calms challenge but when I see a
lot in credit unions is that we do that
marketers are held to an ROI to push us
very specific product that they have to
take that to the board it has to get
approved it's like marketing by
committee we are kind of hamstringing
our marketing teams within our credit
unions that they can't just freely post
on snapchat when they wake up in the
morning and say I'm so jazzed to go to
my credit union this is my story we camp
that down that's how do we shift that a
that's why so few people know about this
period and
you changed the rules from the top like
again I don't how could the CEO in this
room raise your hands
geez one more time just hold them up
it's on these lovely people she's in
charge it's up to her and by the way I
have empathy listen I've spent an
enormous amount of time and this is this
is an absolute bragging moment I've
spent enormous amounts of time in the
White House with the president United
States to go through the legalities of
comms for financial institutions and
other things there's plenty that you can
be doing it's a complete and utter
cop-out to use it on compliance and
rules it's that you don't understand it
fully you don't understand the ROI and
it's fine but there's a guys there's a
very big difference between branding and
marketing and sales they have different
functions and way too many people think
that marketing and branding is sales
it's not and sales is important I'm a
Salesman
I'm a salesman who just happens to
respect what branding and marketing does
because it makes my job easier because
Nike and Apple they don't transact me
these guys don't sell me they won me on
branding I buy it mindlessly okay the
other thing that really pisses me off
sorry we and we talked about this two
years ago but I'm going to pound it
again we lived through a four three
two-and it's still lingering but not as
much missed opportunity by you guys we
live through a three to four year window
where the main competitor banks were the
worst evil in our society and we didn't
pounce on the moment it's true
and so like to be honest with you that
actually gives me very little reason or
hope to think anybody here is going to
do anything about what I'm talking about
you missed the greatest opening of all
time you just let it go by insane
but I think it's so I think it's so here
not as good not as good but not I'm
feeling still there it's always there
but guess what's gonna cost you a hell
of a lot more money not as easy like I
don't want to let them off the hook no
rainbows here you screwed up okay well
I'm going to be the Pollyanna and say I
think that that was a big thing we're
going prompted on my we can't see the
audience we can't end the half life so I
better help life a lot okay
hi Gary question for you so first of all
it's terrifying asking you a question
[Laughter]
second of all this is not my question
but it regreat if you could run for
president instead of the selection that
we have so that's the next thing I was
born in a foreign country so they won't
let me go but I promise you I would make
a run if I could so my actual question
is I'm actually a customer of yours I
have bought wine from your wine site
thank you so much I actually bought it
the first time I heard you speak and I
went right out and bought some so as a
consumer of yours I follow you on
facebook as well you've yet to reach out
to me as your customer and ask me why I
haven't bought from you in the last
eight months so what do you do a you
listen to your customers and B what do
you do to instill an allow change from
your employees within your own company
so we have a pretty so we've been
running data on remarketing for a long
time a Wine Library so Wine Library I
haven't run actively for four years but
your second point is far more important
to me because you're right it's all
about scalability right like I can't do
everything myself I can't call you
necessarily so we ran data on
remarketing to two non returning
customers over a seven-year period from
1999 to 2006 and the cadence on the
recall for us is actually now one year
like we were finding that too many
customers if we really aggressively
tried to get them into the rebuttal
within three six even nine months which
is where I had it for a long time and I
think we went to a year a year ago so
maybe I don't know exactly the details
on your transaction one of the things
that we did four or five years of those
creative Thank You Department because I
wrote a book called the thank you
so when you get hit up in four months
it's going to start with a phone call
because we think the human element has
much more aural ID than the email
element and obviously there's a lot of
ways to go about it but at Wine Library
we see our M you know the 1.2 million
customers that have come through the
funnel through the years pretty
aggressively and remarked it
we even did something where I'm trying
to call my own bullcrap we just did a
direct mailing piece because I always
and I mean this I always like I don't
I'm not a technologist meaning I'm not
obsessed with Facebook and snapchat I'm
obsessed with the price of attention
right so like direct mail is expensive I
guess the stamp cut went down two cents
but I'm always triple checking if it's
still ROI positive but they answer your
question on the main or media side where
we work b2b we have a hundred two
hundred point customers that we work
with and we kind of watch their social
what do they care about we say very high
touch on the wine ecommerce business
that has a hell of a lot more customers
our remarketing when they're out
obsession starts at one year and gets
more aggressive at the two year point
but what's even more interesting and
I'll add on to your questions is the
right energy of a question what we're
doing with people that are in the cycle
lately has been even more fascinating
which is we reared triple Downing on
using technology as a gateway drug to
human interaction so we're spending a
ton of time now mapping people's
Instagram and Twitter accounts figuring
out what they care about and then using
that as a proxy to get them into a phone
call conversation actually what would it
look like if we had 80 phone people that
used technology and big data to create
more meaningful relationships knowing
your key events one things I'm building
right now it's actually done I'm just
testing it is on your account at Wine
Library if you want to give it to me and
we're going to ask for it very black and
white no tricks no games we're going to
say hey we'd like to know the birthdays
and biggest events in your life and if
you want to give them to us the ten days
leading up to it we will give you
recommendations online and free shipping
predicated on anniversaries birthdays
things of that nature and plenty people
will think that's creepy and privacy way
more going to think it's a service and
good and so
hacking away hacking away interesting
flip on that a little work in the
financial sector on the negative side of
this and so insurance is the one I know
the best worse is it insurance has such
a negative conversation with the market
to the point where the rest of it isn't
in the u.s. most insurance policyholders
only speak to their provider maybe one
to one point one times a year seventy
five of those discussions are negative
so same item it means it's a claim a
complaint or a cancellation so they get
when you think I own insurance everyone
has it even as a consumer have a very
negative perception of that brand so
every time you speak to that brand it's
like like asking Gary a question where
we're look there's another thing that's
emerging guys which is time is becoming
the number one asset right besides
health and well-being and money time is
emerged as one of the core things and
our pillars so you know one of the crazy
things back to the phone thing that's
interesting that we're trying to do
we're fighting a trend that I believe
watch this by show of hands and remember
that lying is the devil how many people
here are now mad when another human
being
calls them on the phone raise your hands
raise it high this is super interesting
now we're in a place now where
technology has gotten into a place where
you don't understand why somebody's
calling you they should email or text
you and you will get back to them on
your time I mean literally and so we're
just living through a lot of changes in
our sister guys this is the single
biggest culture shift of communication
in our society in the last 70 years I
mean this is a big deal this
transformation to the Internet age and
to the mobile age this is a major shift
and it has massive repercussions on our
businesses so I mean what do you think
is the biggest opportunity for credit
unions right now given this mobile shift
well first very very honestly what I'd
like to do is look under the hood on a
P&L in one of these CEOs and understand
what they spend their money on to try to
make the thing that they want to make
happen so I think the biggest
opportunity is once the
last time everybody here who runs one of
these businesses sat down and looked at
every dollar deployed on people
infrastructure marketing the whole mine
and said what does this penny do for me
to get what I want the problem is that
80% of the behavior that is being done
by companies is things that have been
accepted as tried-and-true or cost of
business or just things that they're
accustomed to in that 80% 50% of that
stuff is vulnerable I'd like to take
that 50% and get them to start using
against modern behavior that can lead to
a funnel of acquisition of the kind of
clientele that they're going to be
looking for for them to be in business
over the next decade that's what we do
on it she's got a question we're - Mike
question here for the audience yeah
there's winelibrary.com have a mobile
app No so we've been mobile optimized
but we don't have a mobile app I'm truth
be told it's really interesting like
we've uh we've a/b tested that a little
bit but you know I'm not running the
business day in and day out anymore and
to air a little bit of dirty laundry my
dad my dad is a cliche operator that
bothers me the way he operates you know
I'm not there every day it's a family
business and you can imagine there's
enormous emotion around family
businesses he ran it for a while I ran
it for a while changed the landscape of
the business I'm doing other things and
I even though my dad knows what I do for
a living and grow other people's
businesses he's pretty steadfast on
doing certain things the way he wanted
to do them it has not worked over the
last three or four years and now finally
I'm back to like doing certain things so
like that's what's happening there I
mean this kind of reminds me when you
were talking before about like so what
you know the world is changing just get
with it right where's the point where
you throw the baby out with the
bathwater in terms of wisdom but that
older generation brings and sort of like
the way we used to do things there's
there is a wisdom that you have to carry
with you as you adapt where's the line
there for you there's no blanket
statement that would answer this - one
more time how many CEOs in this room
raise your hand you know do I believe
50% of these people should be fired yes
but I just don't know which 50% right so
and what I mean by that is in the
scenario and obviously I'm going for
shock effect what's like saying that to
the people that just raise your hands
but the truth is it's the ones in this
room who've used wisdom and convert it
into romance and being romantic about
how you do things is the quickest way to
go out of business I just don't know
which ones are romantic and only
leveraging wisdom right and I don't know
which ones are just not knowledgeable
what what the alternatives are and
they're open to it but their partners or
their people in their organization
haven't broken through to them and put
them in that position
yeah has there been a moment with you
and your father where he has sort of
shown you the light on something where
you were like oh my god ways aren't
working yeah
not one day off so look I mean I took
over my dad's business it was three
million dollars a year on 10% gross
profit which means it was making
$300,000 a year before expenses and in
five years with no cash infusion I grew
it from three to sixty five million in
revenue like I know what the hell I'm
doing but did my dad teach me things of
course when I was 16 years old my dad
grabbed me by the arm and said you just
bought your first wine order as a 16
year old about a bunch of cases of
something and he looked at me and said
if you change your mind between today
and when the order comes in you'll drink
every one of those bottles you will not
cancel that order and he said this is
the most important thing in life and it
was the best peace advice I've ever
given because as you can tell I'm a more
refined version of myself at 40 imagine
how full of crap I was at 16 so so so
sure but but listen at the end of the
day results are results you know I knew
what I was doing
there's a reason the business has been
flat since I've left there's a reason
that in the last four years that I've
run vaynermedia it's gone from 3 to 100
million dollars in revenue like I got
plenty of stake along with the
showmanship that I deploy here on stage
I just happen to do both
but I not really most of the arguments
my dad and I had in that 8 year period
where I really ran it I won almost every
one of them
that's just the truth because my dad is
romantic and emotional and I'm not
because I know the market doesn't give a
crap about me yeah good question a video
Gary first a a blatant suck-up I agree
with you completely about the results of
2008 to the current period but I think
the reason is and with all due respect
to co-op that we've got a bifurcated
industry we have to trade organizations
we have multiple plastic card services
we have multiple networks yep we don't
cheat we don't talk with one voice to
the American public
there are 6,500 credit unions we talked
with 6,500 Plus voices and we get lost
in the noise I think that's an easy way
to pass on the buck my belief is that if
there were that one of the top 10 credit
unions actually did the actions and did
the marketing themselves that they could
have dragged everybody along I mean why
didn't they you know truth is I don't
want to pontificate on on stage I don't
know maybe they thought that they were
associated with financial institutions
I'm not sure maybe it wasn't in their
financial vested interest maybe they
didn't understand how to make youtube
videos in Google AdWords during that
time I don't know but what I do know is
that it didn't happen and what I do know
is I've never seen a co-op move in
industry I've seen leaders within the
industry do something it worked
and then everybody followed it
so we've spoken about on the negative
side what they're not doing what the
company in the financial services sector
is doing a good job I'm not sure because
you know what I what I know is this
here's what I know and a lot of this is
headline reading and I'm scared of that
so my all my answers are about to be
completely unofficial because I hate
anointing things if I don't know under
things under the hood but I do know from
a branding standpoint that MX is Small
Business Saturday is the kind of way we
need to be thinking about it like the
data that I've looked at and I don't
know how successful it was compared to
what they spent against it to make it
happen but when you look at conversion
rates of small businesses who are not
happy with how much percentage MX takes
and had a lot of energy to push you
towards Visa and MasterCard over the
last seven years of that Small Business
Saturday campaign they've been able to
win more accounts in small businesses
around around the country on the
branding that their small business
friendly even though they're still
taking 1.3 percent more of the
transaction than their competitors so
that to me is interesting you know that
to me is interesting I think when you
look at a firm a new organization that
lets people pay on websites in
installments instead of one transaction
when you look at how PayPal did customer
acquisition there there's things out
there mint and things that there's
certain things out there but to this I
don't like to you know I don't spend a
lot of time looking at what people are
doing outside of me or my clients even
the competitors of my clients so I'm not
I'm not sure because my North Star for
doing something well isn't you liked
their commercial or you like their
campaign or you thought this bank or
this credit union did a nice job on the
Instagram I want to know what that money
that they spent on meant to their bottom
line as a business and without looking
under somebody's hood and understanding
that I just don't know so what I mean
right and saying you don't County have a
financial services client so we we do
but I'm under a lot of NBA's we have a
new one a big one we have one of the
three top banks we literally ironically
today while I was in the park
a lot won a massive piece of business
from them we were working with one of
the top four credit card companies in
America we didn't see the world the same
way and I'm super rich already I don't
need clients that aren't going to do the
behavior that is interesting for me to
learn from so that one ended whom you
would like to be a Gary benetech client
now there's a question every yell yeah
Gary Gary you've indicated that you
think that being emotional and romantic
is a fatal flaw in a business but that
you rely heavily on being empathetic yes
can you help me parse those two concepts
yeah the contradictions so way to sniff
it out so you know I think that I think
that way too many people when I say
emotional and romantic they are not
respecting what the market is doing I
actually think they're completely
opposite things I use empathy to try to
figure out what the market is doing and
then give them what they want and I
define being romantic and emotional
about things is something's happening
that's not in your best interest in the
market but you don't want it to happen
so you could create a delusional
conversation with yourself making
pretend it doesn't happen or worse and
this one's really this really is a big
one or worse you as a human being
recognize that you're not going to be in
that company two or three years from now
and taking money and investing in the
logos health in a decade is going to
lower the margin and profits for the
company over the next two years which
means when you leave it you don't leave
with as much money personally because
you weren't as profitable because you
invested into the future that didn't
have immediate returns
Dave it's true it's true there are a lot
of CEOs that run companies that know
that they're not going to be there in 24
36 months that know the math behind
their bonuses which are completely based
on P&L profit and to be successful in
six years from today you need to deploy
money to have the infrastructure and the
capabilities for six years from today
the problem is you're going to be on
your yacht or playing golf and so you
don't personally get benefited for the
investment in the company so you as a
human and I don't blame you humans are
flawed
do behavior that's in your best interest
as Rick and Sally not in the best
interest of XYZ credit union that's real
like that's real would say would be oh
wait that's why so much doesn't happen
yeah I just wheel I'm glad you stood up
for that I think that was important I
think it's important by the way and I'm
gonna say this Who am I to judge I don't
get the judge I'm not judging you
I'm just telling you what's happening in
the game and you all know it so we
talked we talked a little bit about I
mean just to sort of bring this back
into practical application a little bit
if you were sitting in CEO position at a
credit union you were thinking I'm out
of here in two to three years but I need
to invest a decade from now what's what
would you do the first thing I would do
back to that safe selfish human behavior
is understand that if I did everything
right over the next two or three years
I'd probably sit on three really good
boards of public companies and make a
hell of a lot more money than what I was
trying to milk out of my own company
over the next three years that's number
one that's practical look doing the
right thing is always the right thing
you know we're just always looking in
short-term behavior all the big the
arbitrage that I live in is I'm doing
marathon running behavior in a world of
sprinters I understand the energy I
deploy onstage but let me uncuff in a
hares costume
that was interesting okay but that's
what I am like my decision-making is
based on what I think consumers are
going to be doing today and not just
today end in 24 36 48 months and I run
my organization's based on that that's
what I think a CEO should do while
you're getting paid and running a
company you need to think about the
company not only in the short term but
in the long term and you have to make
those financial bets and you have to
create the infrastructure for your
organization to do those things because
if you do it you will be rewarded
historically by the market of doing
smart things which will then lead to
enormous upside for you in the world
post your being the active CEO of that
company with all the other benefits of
the business world grants you when you
are historically correct I don't get to
sit up here and get paid a lot of money
to do speaking engagements because I'm
Razzie or I make a joke or I'm
confrontational it's because I have
results and because your Razzie auntie
fun sure I mean it's that's you know
what that's the nice to have but the
punchline you know this the punchline is
seven years ago when everybody was a
social media expert I'm the one who
emerged and built an actual business I'm
the one that Toyota and GE and Unilever
is thrilled to point to and say they
helped our business to I'm the one who
sells hundreds of thousands of books in
the first week when other social media
experts that try to sell you social
media advice come out with a book and
sell a thousand copies in four months
shouldn't they use their advice to sell
their book sure so so I mean bringing
back home like what was something which
has a personal angry moment what would
something you did seven years ago that
people were looking at you like that's
crazy every thinking everything I'm
aggressive elaqid in 1996 when when I
launched the third ecommerce wine
business in America people laughed at my
dad for letting their kid ruin his
business guys 20 years ago a lot of you
thought the internet was a fad just
let's just cut to the chase if you even
knew what it was when I bought Google
AdWords my dad it was
the only thing my dad ever fought me on
he didn't want me to do it because he
told me our competitors were going to
click our ads and make us pay for ads
that we weren't going to convert when I
started my youtube show four months
after YouTube started when nobody in the
world knew what it was and I was sitting
in front of it tasting wine and creating
content and bringing value to people my
entire organization thought I lost my
mind they didn't know what YouTube was
when I invested in and then spent 10
hours a day on Twitter in 2007 and 8
everybody thought I was stupid so I mean
it sounds to me like when we drill down
it's not so much I'm in short-term
thinking I want to sit on my yacht but
like it takes a lot of courage to be
doing the same to be sitting in from the
camera never and thinks you're not right
and so how do we instill you know a more
bold bulb from the camera is a different
thing because you have to have the you
know vanity and and other things that
one would need to like put themselves
out there and I recognize those traits
the Twitter things more interesting I
thought it was going to be important and
so I put the time to become a
practitioner not a headline reader so it
doesn't take courage to do it it takes
time it takes time and I promise you if
the CEOs in this room audited what they
do at their time they could find 20% of
it that's being spent on ludicrous stuff
that doesn't bring any more value any
more and they could deploy that to
learning this new world and then
becoming practitioners so that she and
he can be the judge and jury of the
partners and the heads of marketing and
actually hold them to a standard that
needs to be held to in today's
environment guys technology is not a
sector technology is all encompassing
this is not a nice-to-have
or a division this is the world we now
live in it's going to eat up everything
it got to bookstores early it's gotten
to hotels and taxi and limos recently
it's going to get to everything just a
matter of time we still having there is
not one part of a credit news yeah let's
put this I just have a statement not a
question I'm a CEO of a credit union and
we do think long term yeah this is not
the American Bankers Association yes
and we do think long term bankers do
think quarter by quarter by quarter so
that's number one number two there is a
missed opportunity real quick my friend
I don't think in the advice that you're
giving people because I'm grounded in
that I mean in running the business and
we understand that okay right
and so I've got two branches that won't
be profitable until after I'm gone right
okay and you know I we're not thinking
thinking short-term so so the other
thing is in 2008 there was a missed
opportunity it's back okay and the
reason is because it's election year
secondly big short you mentioned yes
everybody understand that understood
that right yes so election year big
short the budget deal in 2015 yes in
December the bankers pulled dodd-frank
out everybody missed it so if we had one
voice speaking about that we've got
another opportunity so I just want to
let you know that we are Byford but
bifurcated I do believe that too and
that's a problem but if we did have a
one voice yes that went after this yes
the American public would understand
that let's stay on this cuz I agree and
I appreciate the inner door bringing
yesterday yesterday a hundred different
videos on Facebook with no money
whatsoever hundreds of dollars of ad
placement reached over ten million
people on organic virality based on its
subject matter your ability tomorrow as
an organization to make a video on this
story to educate the American people
without any of your friends in here
joining you spending a thousand two
thousand dollars to produce it whether
you and I think you come across great so
if you want to do it or if somebody else
wants to do it fine and then spending
another two thousand dollars on ad spend
against fans of Bernie Sanders fans of
Donald Trump fans of Hillary you know
the political or other different
segmentations fans of banks fans of
organizations fight the bank America for
this what have you all segmentations
that you can target on Facebook if you
did that five seven eight times if you
get one that goes viral Mazel Tov you've
won if not if you spent a couple of
hundred thousand dollars you could
blanket
the entire country and give them that
message that's what I'm passionate about
which is that it doesn't cost a lot of
money in 2017 to hit the American people
it's just that we're not respecting the
marketing tactics that can get us there
I agree and I'll just finish with this
that again we're short we're not
short-term thinkers or long-term and
finally bring back glass-steagall and
stop talking about taxation you may not
understand what I just said but I think
the rest of the room did bring back
glass-steagall attack the bankers
because I'm tired of getting attacked
for you good luck I want to add on that
the one Trent when can you bring that
chill in the back I have a real question
because I'm actually curious from my own
education when he when he says he's
tired of getting attacked is there a
feeling within the industry that the
American the end consumer sir when you
said yes tired of getting my carpet sit
down I'm sorry
you want me to come up to see ya oh yeah
when he figured I was fascinated by that
end statement when you said you're tired
of getting attacked do you notice the
American consumer has the credit union
in that position no I I think that I I
think they've long since it's like
they've obituaries but we have a huge
opportunity here this is all going on
right now where bankers you know they've
got no firewall between deposits and
loans and selling it off to the world
right it's nothing's changed listen your
government you're preaching I I made a
reference about I can't wait for the
next one and if you know but real quick
just for my own education cause I'm
curious when you said I'm tired of being
attacked yeah the debate between banks
and credit unions is all about taxation
which is meaningless to everybody I
decide to point 7 billion to the to the
Treasury right which is a teardrop but
think of how much money the banks cost
Oh American people you preach and the
message is not kidding you think any
normal American knows about this debate
between the credit you back I think they
understand that banks created it I think
there's a message problem with regards
to getting that message out to the
American people from the credit union
industry it's not there
huge opportunity here is so there is
actually a large movement it's probably
coming out of Canada at the moment of a
consumer movement back against the
ethics of how banks make money the
reality is Gary has a space out for
ducks I need a thousand bucks there's
other company in between that makes that
transactions happen to that particularly
the unsecured lending space the ethics
of how much margin they make to make
that transaction is getting questioned
in a number of markets there is a 13
year old girl that has an amazing
YouTube video that questions how banks
make money on unsecured lending that has
created a whole tidal wave of consumer
negative sentiment around how banks make
money which is why if you look at the
most successful been tech startups today
they're all about how do we connect to
individuals of course they make p2p
lending it's p2p foreign exchange but I
think it's dangerous you know the
context of me saying we missed an
opportunity it's not about bashing the
banks it's about getting people to
understand what we bring to the table
yeah this is not a we need to spend
money bashing them out or amplifying
that 13 year olds video it's how are we
communicating to the end consumer to
create consideration for me to give you
my money versus the alternatives that
have marketed and now positioned your
organization's in the marketplace and to
me when you look at what's happening in
marketing today the brands and this is
happening absolutely in the political
races
everyone's a hose this or how did Obama
happen how's this Trump thing happening
easy they're using the things I'm
talking about this is not complicated
right
how did Under Armour catch up to Nike
easy they're using the things that I'm
talking about how did honest company and
method become real competitive Johnson
Johnson Unilever and Procter & Gamble
easy they're using the things that I'm
talking about so it's about the
opportunities in a digital environment
to create content and target people with
the messaging that we want them to know
that tactic and understanding that
religion is the white space yeah that
was like I don't I get so Sam would
actually like love this the message you
want to tell your consumer is Sam
recruit up in the very first purpose
video that should be your brand that was
an amazing video Sam I are for you
mister sorry guys all about the purpose
of a credit union but that is the brand
that's anarchy
you need to make the market understand
it's already there or real quick cause
I'll just leave a tactical thing for you
it's not we don't know but you can spend
very little money deploying this in a
facebook video environment and reaching
tens of millions of people and seeing
how they react to it in the comments
qualitative feedback at scale and you
can make 40 different messages like for
the credit unions they don't you guys
don't need you know the milk campaign
you don't need one shining star that's
going to save it all you need to have a
process that makes eighty-seven
different potential stories and videos
go through the Facebook environment that
has hundreds of millions of users on it
and see what people react to and then
triple down on that yeah got it
yeah I'm gonna stop us here but I think
that this is a great place to end
there's I think limitless opportunity I
have sort of a glass half full here and
I appreciate those comments and we
certainly given us a lot of food for
thought so we're going to take some time
to jump on that thank you thank you
thank you guys thank you for having with
us
[Applause]
[Music]